good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is Margaux and welcome back to the
markable are shopping hour I've got a
brand new product for you for all your
farming equipment needs because I'm your
number one source of farming equipment
absolutely the brand-new product that's
going to allow the nation vinod open
eyes 4,000 vinod urbanized 4000 is now
capable of far more tilling than your
field ever could handle it can plow Wow
in both directions it's a plural word
monster capable of completing everyday
tasks to extreme efficiency
it's a bi-directional knot of an eyes
twice as good better than the previous
version it also comes with convenient
grabby handles for your everyday farming
needs because we handle farming needs
and nothing else please don't give us
calls for anything else that's 188 don't
call me madam an eyes comes complete
with full hydraulic system so that you
can impress the ladies when you're on
the road yeehaw
buckaroo knives is conveniently
unbreakable the knives can succeed in
the most inhospitable of locations and
went hope seems gone the new and
improved and improved not urbanize has
been known to be expert in handling of
livestock even though that sheep just
killed itself but livestock are a very
important part of your everyday farm
knees and we here and not a fan dies
incorporated know that your property
needs to be properly handled such that
you can go about your daily life knowing
that everything Oh God as I was saying
the knives is new and improved in any
way you can plow twice as much field as
you could possibly handle your wife of
farming will be totally surprised at the
knot of an Isis capabilities not in that
way don't be dirty can you remind out of
the gutter please ours is a respectable
product made by a respectable company
made from respectable people in some
countries that we legally can't name so
by not open eyes tonight today what time
is it today
my not if a knives is out of control it
can't possibly
this sheep of this magnitude oh boy
something seems to have gone horribly
wrong
come here little sheep II the
non-urbanized wants to show you its
features hey I got that sheep all of
your attachments that you bought for the
original not urbanized 3000 can be
retrofitted to become part of your new
and improved not open eyes behold the
cropped flamethrowers for farming for
those pesky livestock often give you
sass well shut them up for good with the
new not a fan eyes Oh as you can see the
not a fan eyes comes with full 360
degree turning radius with twice the
amount of balls penises uh tires that we
had before behold sheepy come towards me
wow that was weird but not of an eyes is
so versatile that it can function on
just one set of ball wheels wheels you
can't stop my undulation Schieffer Unni
yes it's worm my way wow that poor sheep
just exploded out of an eyes not of an
eyes you're the best farming tool we've
had you help our farms for some damn
reason we don't know why but we're
really really grateful we give you all
our money because we want them not even
eyes we want it today and oh god oh god
and nothing else to say that it's not
farming equipment because it is time to
unleash hell congratulations yeah the
nice is a winner in everybody's books
and every farmer should own one today
but not urbanize is so durable that it
can actually climb this mountain oh crap
now introducing the knot of an eyes
light because sometimes size isn't
everything sometimes you have a small
farm that needs small tilling
capabilities well we are in not a fan
eyes of introducing the not urbanized
light because sometimes you're tilling
capabilities aren't as dramatic as
people say they are but you still need
the double ploughing action that allows
easy access
say hello to the neighbors not of an
eyes hooray and we're still in one piece
but they aren't and that's all that
matters in life my wheels exploded but
the knot of knives will not explode for
you ah the knot urbanize can be
turbocharged to be able to make those
tight corners Oh God
ah crap sometimes the best Avenue is
just to charge forward blindly and then
blow away for those uncertain crop
fields you don't know what you plan it
introducing the even mini are not
urbanized capable of even tighter turns
than ever thought possible now we know
exactly what technology is supposed to
me well [ __ ]
god damn it Wow whoa
not urbanized is rounded over backwards
not even eyes Beast oh [ __ ] whoa hey
whoa we flipped upside down the holoband
eyes seems to be out of control but it's
very excited about the prospects of
farming farm farm got a farm farm away
oh [ __ ]
god damn it [ __ ] a duck oh [ __ ] no
farming farming farming is my life
farming is my life farming is my life oh
god it's hard to drag this big thing
around you know what I'm very good come
on kids
oh come on bake it bake it bake it up
the hill I just got to push it along
with the non-urbanized as custom
hydraulic oh yeah nice one for the whole
family
did really RJ NIH's ordered a day
sometimes the original is indeed the
best not in this case though not
urbanize knows no limits
maybe the Namdaemun eyes is known a
limit can I just could I just please
please move forward could I please I do
not want to engage the not upon eise's
functionality I just need to move
forward just a little more Oh Joe jostle
that bomb you bastards
blam that did do nothing not have an
eyes oh wow
you missed me well how about a little
bit of wait wait wait for it you're
gonna get yours eventually just wait
little man the not open eyes the not
open eyes has conquered all the
non-urbanized is unbeatable the not open
eyes is available today the not open
eyes 3000-4000 and the new-and-improved
not of an eyes light so order yours
today remember the number because I
don't I hope you remember in the last
episode because I really don't so
remember our motto life is hard
shouldn't you be to still sounds weird
when saying now but thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always you
can buy one
[Music]
damnit not urbanize has two convenient
ball holders in the front